today it's like christmas for nfl fans
but instead of
new presents to unwrap it's new players
that are getting drafted to their teams
tonight is the first round in cleveland
hector mejia is live here in las vegas
he's outside legion stadium
with a look at what the las vegas
raiders are going to be doing in the
draft hector good morning
hey there john good morning to you so
the draft always an exciting time for
sports fans of course next year las
vegas will get to host the draft
and for now fans are looking forward to
find out what the raiders will do this
time around for the draft
their second draft here in las vegas and
the raiders have the 17th overall pick
in tonight's opening round
unless they decide to trade up or down
the team is pretty well set at some key
positions including quarterback
running back and wide receiver they are
expected to target the
offensive line or grab a defensive back
with their first pick
team general manager mike mayok says
this is going to be a very different
draft because of the pandemic there was
no combine
and no chance for teams to sit down face
to face with the players
we still had to do some zoom meetings
this year i don't like that
even though we get a lot of information
and we got after it it's not the same as
sitting down with a kid having dinner
with them having lunch with them
watching tape with them it's a little
different conversation
mayok would not tip his hand about which
way the team plans to go in tonight's
first round and keep in mind
the draft is happening over three days
tonight tomorrow and saturday still
ahead of the next half hour
you'll hear from one local player
waiting to have his name called
we'll have that part of the draft still
ahead in the next half hour
reporting live outside allegion stadium
this morning hector mejia
8 news damn hector thank you very much
it'll be cool to see the players
celebrate and hug their moms and their
families around them when they get
chosen by a team it's always fun to
watch we'll catch up with that
later tonight appreciate that it's now
609